you want to know how bad college has
become one school regarded as the tops
in journalism is saying they'll no
longer report on the news if it upsets
activists the daily Northwestern the
student paper for Northwestern published
a hilariously pathetic apology to
activists after covering a speech on
campus by Jeff Sessions activists felt
the event shouldn't be covered because
they prefer that their opinions only be
heard the cowardly paper caved like a
cheap tent apologizing for sending a
reporter to cover the event invalid
pathetically that from now on the only
cover stuff that doesn't hurt their
feelings think about that a newspaper
apologizing for reporting the news
that's like a dentist apologizing for
filling a cavity or me for filling you
with such great knowledge it's another
example of how the lunatic fringe has
silenced dialogue by smearing it as
hateful or harmful mind you the loudest
worst kinds of expression sometimes even
violent comes from these wimpy twerps
yet they don't see their psychic
violence's arming other people why is
that it's College a corpse rotting from
within and so while the paper pretends
to cover news it'll be the news that the
activists approve of meaning the papers
editors they just quit their jobs and
handed it over to the activists which
may be why real journalism is dying now
that's a stressful news story which will
probably go unreported to Dana this is
disgusting but not surprising just
thinking that like you've come to
actually you've couldn't just expected
yeah from all across the board from like
a Northwestern I would have loved to
have gotten into Northwestern yessum
school where is it they should be more
specific about the title then
Northwestern is too vague I think that's
the area of the city right one yeah
actually it's right outside in the
suburbs here
I'm already against it then one just by
the name just by the what do you are a
journalist you've been writing books for
every work for the Washington Post been
every this has got to get in under your
skin a little bit oh yeah I wrote a book
about this several years ago called
muzzle the assault on honest debate
night I think there is an assault on
honest debate so you know but I just
wanted to that the audience everybody
should know I mean part of this is about
immigration and about people who are
under
documented or illegal aliens in
protesting and then saying oh my
pictures in the paper
why then I'm gonna be on a call and
throw me out that's on them for being
dumb enough to get their picture taken
or in the case of like Harvard yeah
however got into this situation as well
they were saying why are you calling ice
why are you why do you get involved with
this organization that wants to deport
my grandma or is busting into somebody's
business to throw people in jail but at
that point that's why you get like the
news today from Harvard was that the
student government at Harvard sided with
the protesters against the newspaper
yeah and they're saying that well I can
see that's a public political expression
of support like athlete church
supporting sanctuary cities but that's
not journalism journalism is to tell the
story call people on both sides and get
it out that that's a point to Katie is
that they were didn't like being called
so how does it work or to his job if you
can't call people for a quotes okay you
don't answer the phone you're obligated
to talk to reporters but they can call
you if you're your numbers in public
record the most alarming part of this
editorial to me is when they say while
our goal is to document history and
spread information nothing is more
important than ensuring that our fellow
students feel safe right we can't talk
about anything that makes us
uncomfortable if you can't cover Hong
Kong protests if you're living in China
because that might disrupt your safe
little world that we've created for you
right and it might make you question why
things are the way that they are and I
want to applaud the Dean for defending
the journalists for the original story
that they produce because a lot of the
time these university administrators do
the opposite and they coddle them and
take challenges away and that doesn't
help them when they get out into the
real world but the people who wrote this
editorial are probably going to try and
get jobs and newsrooms once they get out
of college and that's the social media
to me I mean I think this editors
probably already been hired by see yes
that's true looking for someone with
experience and retraction since spiking
stories what I don't understand about
this is Jeff Sessions is traumatized
yes he's like five one doesn't have a
job all right it's not like Jeff
Sessions is 911
you don't get traumatized by Jeff
Sessions the only person actually
traumatized by sessions is Trump yeah
yeah you should have recused if you
don't lean on recused we wouldn't have
the witch-hunt but I do I do understand
the students anxiety about getting a
phone call if you're like 1819 and your
phone rings that is terrifying no one
calls you with that it that means it's
either your parents or a bill collector
hmm so if you're you know people DM at
that age that could be scary yeah I
didn't see that angle coming yeah Jesse
always all the angles great yeah you
know what the kids are thinking right